[Music]
real quick let's fangirl okay happy yeah
honey yes Queen shows a surprise to
everyone when you met him what was going
through your mind and more importantly
how did boyfriend react oh my god well I
mean I left when I was talking to my
boyfriend about her he was like it's
like he met the male Beyonce and I was
like thank you that's why I love my
boyfriend because he is so awesome he's
so incredible but it was great too
because right before I went to do
Colbert I got my hands stuck in the
window of the car and I'm really cry
very easily but it was like it shocked
me and I was tearing a little bit I was
like oh no this is gonna be terrible and
they were like Brad Pitt's here and I
was like we're good we're good
um no but then I like walk up the stairs
and I go wouldn't be crazy if we walked
into boom oh hi hi yeah Gina yeah is he
the same one that you hired for me yes
he's the only surprise you know it was
so great to see him reprises character
on Jane the Virgin in last week's
episode how much fun is that for you to
have him on set with you oh it's the
absolute best not to mention it was
Jenny ermine that did it it wasn't even
like a request Jenny is so fantastic and
for her to bring him back was like
really super though she's just awesome
and Joe has so much fun and he's like
such a good sport about it you know so
it was very very cool he looks good
shirtless I mean all the things all the
things he's opted